The truth is when producers wanted me to be
sexy but always with some absurd spin on it,
that made me feel like I was still in control.
What happened in the last five years, real fans probably knew deep down that there was something going on.
Paranoia, fear, body pain, anxiety.
I go from everyone touching me all day
and talking at me all day to total silence
and all these people will leave and then I'll be alone.
I didn't feel good enough and I do now.
That's the good part.
I have chased this pain for five years, but when I feel the adrenaline of my music and my fans, I can fucking go.
My family is the most important thing in my life.
Hi, Grandma!
Hello there.
She died when she was 19.
I can always bring my past with
me, but I can never go back.
You got to leave yourself behind.
I want to do the opposite of what
everyone thinks I'm gonna do.
There really isn't anything bigger than this.
Do you have the new Lady Gaga album?
The new lady named what?
Lady Gaga album?
Oh! Do we have them?
Yeah.